sveglia la mattina sveglia dell'indiana
il momento di una prova
la prima prova è la seguente se la prova
vorrei superare il pericolo di snai ma
dovrai trovare se non sai dove cercare
pensano il colore da trovare ma celeste
mai più normali potrei tornare è meglio
che ci sbrighiamo andiamo è apparso
qualcosa nella sfera di cristallo che
furono date la nostra prima sfida
dobbiamo trovare tutti i nuovi slime ha
detto anche un indovinello se non fai
dove cercare il colore dovrei trovare se
il tempo fra impastare mai più normale
potrei tornare ma oggi dobbiamo
sbrigarci a cercarli altrimenti non
potrò mai più tornare normale frontali
non ho capito ma ok andiamo andiamo
cercarvi prete viene scatola vuota
skifidol saker it's like dobbiamo
trovare queste allora vediamo che i
colori ci sono così sappiamo dove sono
nascosti sono 1 2 3 4 5 6 colori di ieri
penso che dobbiamo cercare nei luoghi
degli stessi colori possiamo iniziare
con il verde il verde ottima idea forse
potremmo cercare fuori in giardino che
ne pensi tu stai attenta però la fuori
ea non prendere il volo con queste ali
vitale c'è troppo vento non posso uscire
si romperebbero leali devi andare tu ok
trovato il verde io cercherò dentro
carta di altri colori
sì certo non ti preoccupare lo vado a
cercare io e il verde qui tu contro
un'altra casa ok ragazzi
nel frattempo che vitale cerca lo slang
verde io cercherò lo slime blu quindi
dobbiamo guardarci intorno a cercare
qualcosa di blu in cui potrebbe essere
nascosto in effetti le tende in questo
senso sono c'è qualcosa lassù guardate
potrei volare a prenderlo la somma
ancora non so vuoi fare quindi
semplicemente mi arrampicai rola sopra
andiamo ok sono riuscite a fallire
ora provo a prendere lo slime da sopra
sì l'ho preso
ho preso lo slime speriamo che vi darà
abbiamo trovato quello verde è lassù mi
divertirò meccanico e anche questo è
questa se è corretta
italiane sono moto lo slide verde 2 di 6
ore ne abbiamo due cene manca solamente
4 ok e iniziò a fare il primo
qual è il vostro colore preferito degli
slime facciamo un gioco
lasciate un mi piace su questo video è
l'ultima cifra del vostro mi piace
corrisponde al vostro colore ecco qua i
vari colori quindi ad esempio se il
vostro mi piace il numero tre 141 il
vostro numero 1 e ora andiamo a fare il
primo slime proviamo ad aprirli vediamo
come funzionano questi sono i nuovi
skifidol shaker ruiz lime che potete
trovare in edicola e con questa
confezione si può schierare frizzare
creare lo slime quindi dentro c'è una
free ball slime che si trasforma in
flight vediamo come funziona all'interno
ci sono tutti i componenti per creare il
nostro slime montiamo questo qua e con
questo possiamo andare a mescolare lo
slime ed eccola skifidol fitball da qui
si creerà lo slime per prendere 100 ml
di acqua a temperatura ambiente non
prenderci tennis lino qua nelle
confezioni dello skifidol saker ft
ma poi apriamo la nostra skifidol puzz
ball
mettiamola nel bicchierino poi versiamo
50 ml di acqua lentamente
guardate sta iniziando a fritz ore
ora possiamo chiuderla con il coperchio
e l'intera mescolarlo piano piano la ri
utilizzerò questa confezione perché è
molto comoda ora dopo aver mescolato
possiamo armi aprirlo e aggiungere
lentamente i 50 m
le via ecco fatto sentiamo ok ora basta
farlo riposare per 5 minuti ora che sono
passati cinque minuti dobbiamo
mescolarlo energicamente per 5 minuti
quindi andiamo a mescolare quel che la
parte più divertente
ora che abbiamo finge di mescolarlo
lasciamo riposare lo slide per 30 minuti
sono passati 30 minuti vediamo come ora
lo slime ora dobbiamo mischiarlo per 5
minuti con le mani
vidi avuto eccolo qua queste uscite una
sorta di verde giallino molto stretti e
ziegler
andiamo ora a trovare gli altri ciao
merlino mi aiuti a trovare gli altri
slime grazie per questi boys il secondo
te dove sono gli altri time da me un
indizio berlina sto guardando la sopra i
colori che mancano sono rosa viola
arancione e giallo quindi potrebbe
essere forse qua sotto questo pupazzo
giallo la costante attenzione e ancora
sotto il pupazzo arancione bene abbiamo
un altro time ne mancano solo tre ma
vitale dove sarà finito
vitale o no che cosa ci è successo
vitale o meno male che sai bene per i
saluti avesse preso quella strana
persona dentro alla sfera bensì
effettivamente giardino che stavano
inseguendo una specie di lampi e fulmini
non so che cosa fossero nello specifico
[Musica]
beccato con le analisi qualcosa sopra
sempre a muslime però potrebbero unirsi
qualcosa da dentro mi raccomando attento
ma questo è facile da prendere tanto lo
so che è il benvenuto io scendo da qui
prima che magari di qualche altra
fulmina vediamo se l'altro flavi ma ci
mancano solo due slam quello viola e
quello rosa 6 dovuto nasconderli un
pochino meglio ma senti questo rumore al
piano di sotto per qualcosa al piano di
sotto
forse sono lì gli altri due slime vedi
per il sud operai anche quelli
e successo a cosa ci sia mai stato
dentro la sfera di cristallo che
prendiamo gli ultimi 21 giu rosa e viola
ha avuto che sei e fatele biferi
superare questa prova ma ci sono tante
altre prove che dovrai superare queste
di riuscire a stupire una frase esperta
come me guardate abbiamo creato due
altri laimer skifidol feat
io quello rosa io quello già abbiamo
vinto la challenge potete trovare i
nuovi skifidol sheikh e rfid slime in
edicola in sei colori diversi
basta solo aggiungere l'acqua e potete
creare il vostro slime li trovate in
allegato al magazine in edicola qual è
il vostro colore preferito
scrivetecelo nei commenti era stato un
bel l'ideale se volete vedere altri
video slimer
vi lasciamo quanto possa servire se qui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cade su quella che preferite la visione
ciao